TAL AKABAS: I'm here to
introduce Meg Akabas.
Meg is a certified parenting
educator and the author
of "52 Weeks of
Parenting Wisdom:
Effective Strategies for Raising
Happy and Responsible Kids."
She'll talk about
the book today.
And each chapter of the book
provides a salient piece
of advice on specific
topics concerning parents,
such as respect, self-control,
cooperation, sibling relations,
sleep habits, and more.
Unlike other parenting
books, it mercifully
lets parents concentrate on
making a single change that
is attainable and effective
without being overwhelmed
and distracted with
too much information.
She serves as the steering
committee for the New York
State Parenting
Education Partnership,
and was recently nominated to
serve on the National Parenting
Education Network Council.
Meg has served as the
president of the board of two
schools of Manhattan and
has more than 18 years
of leadership experience in
nursery and elementary schools,
and she's the mother
of four children.
And if you haven't already
guessed, that includes myself.
Here's Meg.
MEG AKABAS: Thanks, Tal.
So can everybody hear me?
That's actually
the first time I've
had one of my kids introduce me.
It was kind of a treat.
I might have to take
him on tour with me.
So thank you all
for coming today.
I'm delighted to see you
here, mostly because it
means that you care
about parenting.
And I believe that
parenting is something
that every parent should work,
on even the best parents.
I think we can all
be better parents.
And there are really
few things in this world
that are more important.
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
I came to write this book, "52
Weeks of Parenting Wisdom."
I'll tell you about two
of the core tenets that
run throughout the book, and
then I'll talk about a couple
of the strategies, and
then I'll have time
for some of your questions,
because I know some of you
probably have parenting
issues you want to ask about.
That's always the fun part.
I came to the field
of parenting education
about eight years ago.
Before that, I was a
management consultant
for nonprofit arts
organizations.
I have an MBA.
I also have a Master's in music.
And I did work in strategic
planning and marketing
and development for
nonprofit organizations.
At the same time that I began
to work right out of business
school, I also started a family.
And for New York standards,
I started very young.
I started to have my
kids in my early 20s,
because I knew I wanted
to have a big family.
Tal is my second of four.
So I really had two
things, I think,
that were going for
me to start with.
And one was that I had
very good role models
as parents-- both my parents
and my husband's parents.
And second, I fell into
mothering pretty naturally.
It was something I felt
pretty comfortable with,
that I enjoyed, and I thought
I was well-suited for.
Despite those really
positive and important points
that I had going for
me, I often felt--
during those first
few months and years,
trying to figure out what I
was doing as a mother-- really
overwhelmed, and very confused,
and not very sure of myself.
So when my instincts
worked, they worked.
And when they didn't, I
wasn't sure what to do.
And for someone who
is type A, as I am,
a planner, feeling out of
control and overwhelmed
didn't feels so good to me.
And I felt like
parenting was something
that I should
approach as I approach
other things in my life--
that it was something
I wanted to work on
and be really good at.
So I began to research and read
and study child development
and go to workshops,
and also my husband
and I discussed child-rearing
pretty much on a nightly basis,
and became more well-informed
about what strategies worked,
what was effective, and what we
knew about child development.
And the more that I
learned, the more I
found that I became much more
confident in my parenting,
and that the decisions that
I made and the parenting
strategies I used
really became effective.
And when my kids got
to be by middle school
age or late
elementary school age,
it just got much easier because
I had put in so much time early
on trying to find
the right strategies
and to be effective
in my parenting.
So when my peers were all
having their children,
I already had several.
And people began to
ask me for advice.
I also was, as Tal said,
president of two school boards.
And people naturally
came to me as a mentor.
And pretty soon my kids
were also saying to me,
you know, Mom, you should
write a book about parenting.
So I began to think about this.
And because I believed
so passionately
that parenting was important--
and that it's much easier when
you learn about it and you
work at it; in the end,
it will be easier
for you-- that I
decided to move into this
profession of parenting
education, which is
actually a profession.
And I became a certified
parenting educator
by pulling in some pieces from
my background and education
that we're missing that
I needed, and began
to work with parents both in
workshops and individually
one-on-one.
And what I found
working with parents
is that they, too, were
overwhelmed, for the most part.
That they were well-intentioned
and they love their kids
and they wanted to
do what was best,
but that they would just sort
of throw up their hands and say,
there's just so
much to worry about,
so much to keep track of.
We're always putting
out the latest fire.
And when I worked with
parents one-on-one
and gave them one thing to
work on for a week or two weeks
until I saw them or
talked with them next,
they were much more likely to
be successful in implementing
what we had talked about.
And that made sense.
Like anything else
we do in life,
it's hard to be good at
something immediately or all
at once.
And to really get your skills
together at the same time,
you layer things one at a time.
So when I began to
write this book,
I decided to take the
approach of really making
short chapters, each about
one salient parenting point,
and that parents would digest
that one piece at a time
and to see parenting
as a journey,
as something
proactively that you
approach throughout your life.
Because you're
really never done.
I mean, I've been
parenting for 27 years,
and I'm still working
on my parenting.
So it's a long haul.
But it's something they really
do see building skills on top
of each other and you
see the rewards of that.
So that's how I came to write
the book "52 Weeks of Parenting
Wisdom."
And there are two overriding
principles or tenets
that I believe
about parenting that
really flow throughout the book.
And the first is that how we
parent matters-- that it really
does make a difference
what you do.
And I know that there
are a lot of naysayers
who say that your children
are born a certain way
and there's very little
you can do about it.
So, don't worry so much.
Just let it go and see
what happens and everything
will turn out fine.
And actually how we
parent really does matter.
And I'm actually part of
an experiment going on,
a research study that's going
on at Columbia University
that I started with my
oldest son when he was born.
I was asked to be
in a study that
is looking at communication
between infants and mothers
and how that
communication keeps going
throughout the life of a child
and into their adulthood.
So it was a continuing
study, and they're
looking at-- I'm in
the control group.
But they're looking at
how trauma or depression
or other things that
might affect the parent
affect their parenting
skills and what effect that
has later on in life.
So I know this, from
the core of my being,
that how we parent
really matters.
And it's why I do the work I do.
The second principle that
runs throughout the book
is an idea of
approaching parenting
with the point of
parenting with intention.
So by parenting
with intention, I
mean the opposite of
responding to the latest
crisis or the latest problem,
that we don't need to do that,
because, of course, we do.
But to go into
parenting with an idea
in mind of what you
want the outcome to be.
So what do you
want for your kids?
And when I ask people that
question, they'll say,
I want my kids to
be happy, or I want
them to grow up to
be successful adults.
Some people say I just don't
want my kids to be messed up.
I hope I just get
them to that point.
And those are all
fine and good goals,
but they're not very specific.
And so when I ask
people to think
about what they want
for their children,
I ask them to think
about what kind of person
do you want your child
to grow up to be?
And what traits do you
want to instill in them?
Not what you want
them to achieve,
because achievement goals
we really have very little
control over.
We do know that
genetically everybody's
born with a certain personality.
They are born with
certain strengths
and certain challenges.
And, yes.
As parents, there's very
little we can do about that.
And we work with those
strengths and challenges
to the best of our
ability, but those things
are things that our
children are born with.
So what we can really
have influence over
is the kind of person they turn
out to be, how they behave,
and how they interact
in the world.
So I encourage parents--
and I did this myself,
with my husband-- to think
about what traits do you really
want your children to have?
And it may not be the same
for everybody in this room,
and that's fine.
But it's really something that
you should have in your mind--
and if you have a parenting
partner, in their mind--
because then all of the
strategies and the tools
that you use to parent
your children can be seen
through that lens of does
this serve my end goal?
You can ask the filter question.
Does bribing my child
at this moment--
is that going to
teach my child what
I want to teach them in the end?
That kind of question.
So for my husband and
I, we had three traits
that we worked to
instill in our children.
And, in no particular
order, the first one
was respect-- that we
wanted to raise children
who respected other people,
had consideration for others,
had consideration for
ideas other than theirs,
who had consideration and
respect for education,
and had a respectful demeanor
in dealing with others.
Secondly, we wanted to raise
children who were sensitive,
who were empathetic, who would
be able to read other people's
feelings and then act
appropriately on those feelings
and have a demeanor of
kindness about them.
And thirdly-- and this
is going to be one thing
that I talk about.
I'm going to pick out a
few chapters of the book
to talk about.
But the third thing,
then-- I'm going
to be more specific
about this later--
is we wanted to have children
who had self-control,
self-discipline, could
live a life of moderation.
There's lots of
different words for this.
But in psychology or the
child development field,
we call it executive function.
And it means having a
well-developed prefrontal
cortex part of your brain,
which helps you to inhibit
urges that will help you to
live a life of moderation.
And I'll talk about why
that's important in a minute.
So those were three things
that we wanted for our children
that we tried to
instill in our children,
and that framed all of
the parenting decisions
that we made.
And I encourage parents
to think about the traits
that you want, in the long
run, to see your children have,
and then use that to guide you.
So I'm going to talk about three
different chapters in the book.
I just pulled them
out-- not randomly,
but they're not in
any particular order.
The first one is from
Week 23, and the chapter
is called "Who's in Charge?"
So I often hear
parents use the phrase,
"my child won't let
me blank." my son
won't wear anything but
the latest Nike sneakers
or my child won't let
me come on field trips
as a parent chaperone,
or my daughter won't
have her birthday
party anywhere else
but where Sally had
her birthday party.
But you can hear how those
words, "my child well let me,"
that phrase, in front
of anything else,
is really a reversal
of authority.
So you may have heard also of
three styles of parenting--
the permissive style of
parenting, where there are
few rules or, if
there are rules,
they're not enforced well.
There's the authoritarian
style of parenting,
where there are very strict
rules that are enforced harshly
with punishment and no
explanation of those rules.
And then there's authoritative.
So authoritarian is the
military-type style,
and then authoritative
is sort of
halfway in between--
it's in the middle
between permissive
and authoritarian.
And authoritative
parenting is when
there are clear rules, where
there are clear consequences.
There's an understanding by
the child of why the rule is
in place and there's also
a lot of positive feedback.
So going back to this idea
of "my child won't let me."
When we hear ourselves saying
that or using that phrase,
we've fallen into the
permissive style of parenting.
And, by the way, there
is a fourth style
of parenting called
uninvolved parenting,
but I'm assuming none of you
are that because you're here.
So I won't even talk about that.
But why it's not a
good thing to fall
in to that permissive
type of parenting
is that children have a
huge need for security.
Other than their basic
needs of food and clothing
and shelter and our love, is
one of their biggest needs.
And being in charge is actually
really scary for children.
Even though at the moment
they may be convincing you
that they want to be in charge,
it's not healthy for them,
and it's very scary for them.
And often it can lead to anger.
So when you see
children who are angry,
who seem to have a
lot of anger problems,
it's often because
they had been parented
in a very permissive style.
And they really
just wanted someone
to tell them right and wrong
and where the boundaries were.
Parents do not need
to get permission
from their children
for decisions
that parents should
be making themselves.
And it's not good for children,
because they look to us
to provide that
structure and guidelines.
I do believe in--
and I believe this
very strongly-- in respecting
children's ideas and opinions.
But it's really
important to not let
a child's request and
opinion about something
override your good
judgment or your values.
So what happens when you
give in to a child who's
in charge of you is that
you not only give in
to the child's demands and maybe
forgo you're good judgment,
but you also miss an
opportunity to teach a lesson.
And that goes back
to the lesson I
was talking about what
traits you want to instill.
Here are some ways we let
our children be in charge.
We let them give us orders.
We let them negotiate us out
of our rules or decisions.
We let them manipulate
us, like, oh, I'll
promise I'll only
do it this once.
They use the other example
of the other parent--
but Daddy lets me do this,
or Mommy lets me do this.
Or sometimes they use other
families or other children
to sway you.
Jenny's parents let her stay
until 11:00, or whatever it is.
Or they might use comments
like, all my friends do it.
Everyone has one.
So it's important
that you listen
to your children's opinions or
their ideas about these things,
but not to be swayed by
what other families do
or what your child
says other children do.
You can say, that's fine.
That's what their family
does, but we do it this way.
So if you feel like you've
given up some parental control
in that area, I encourage you to
take a week and focus on that.
Remember that kids
are really inclined
to test parental authority,
and that being in charge,
in the long run,
it's scary for them,
and they're much
happier in the long run
if you give them that comfort
and security of sticking
to your guns.
Is this ringing true for
anybody here, this idea
of "my child won't let me"?
So the second point I'd like to
talk about is in Chapter Three.
I put this one right near
the front of the book
because I feel like it's such
a prevalent thing right now--
and maybe it has
been for a while.
But the name of this
chapter is "Don't
Ask When you Mean to Tell."
This is a very
common occurrence.
I'm not sure why it's
become so common.
But we, as parents, have
fallen into the trap
of asking our children to do
things that we want them to do
or that they need to do, that
they don't have a choice about.
So instead of saying
something like,
it's time to put on
your coat, we say,
Jane, can you put
on your coat now?
Or, put on your coat, OK, Jane?
And when we say it with a
question, a question mark
or an OK at the end, that's
what our child hears.
They hear that
they have a choice.
And that does include
tacking on the word "OK."
Maybe we do that in the effort
of being polite or nice,
wanting our children to like us.
But what it does is it
confuses our children.
We need to let them know
what's required and what isn't.
So conversely of that,
it's important to also
not to tell your child to do
something if you don't really
mean and you're not
going to follow through.
So you give an
instruction-- stop
bouncing that ball in the house.
And the child continues
to do it and then
you get distracted by
something else-- the phone
or talking to someone else--
and they continue to do it.
And then you need
to make dinner.
It's, you know, it
really doesn't matter.
I'm just going to let
them bounce the ball.
It's easier.
They'll stop in a little while.
And your child continues
until they're done with it,
and now what have they learned?
They've learned that
your words don't
have weight, that what you
said you didn't really mean.
And so that's exactly it.
Our children need to know
that our words have weight
and that they can
trust what we say.
So when I hear parents
say-- and I hear this a lot.
When I hear parents say, "my
children never listen to me."
What that tells
me is it's usually
because the children have
learned that their words don't
have true meaning,
and they've gotten
used to tuning their parents
out because often there's
no consequence if they
tune their parent out.
So my advice-- and
I give some steps
for following this in the
book, in that chapter--
is to first be really
clear in your mind
before something comes out your
mouth about whether the child
has a choice.
I actually heard parents say
to a child who is running out
in a street in New York City.
Their child was about to run off
the curb, and she said, Jason,
can you not run off the
curb into the street?
And when we fall into
the habit of doing that,
if you listen to yourself,
it's important to know
whether you're using
a question or not.
And so if you, in your
mind, know for certain
that you're going to want
you child to do something,
then say, it's time
to do this, or we're
going to do this now,
or please do this.
But don't have your voice
go up like a question.
And so that can really
shift things around.
And that, in conjunction,
with using consequences
and following through if the
child doesn't do what you've
asked them to do will
really make a difference.
And you can find that
your child will really
start to listen to
what you say, and you
won't be saying "my child never
listens to me" because they
know that your words have weight
and that you follow through
and that you mean what you say.
So thirdly, I'd to talk
about a chapter called
"Everything in Moderation."
And this goes back to
that trait that I told you
that was very important for
my husband and I. We felt
like this was
something we wanted
to instill in our children.
So we know that babies
are born without an ounce
of self-control.
Kids start as infants with the
notion of grabbing anything
they want and when they
want and what they want.
This is a really
natural urge, and it's
developed from aeons of
evolution in all animals.
And it shows up in
the everyday thinking
and natural inclinations
of all kids.
Kids only slowly start
to shed this notion
of self-entitlement.
However, babies can begin to
develop self-soothing withing
the first year-- the
beginnings of self-control.
And it's our job to
continue to develop
that self-control
and those skills.
So in today's world,
what's the downside
of lacking self-control?
Some of you have probably
heard of the famous marshmallow
study, which was done here,
at Stanford University,
in the 1960s.
The people who conducted the
study-- the person's name
was Walter Mischel.
It began in the late 1960s.
What he did was he
took 200 children
and individually put them
in a room with a marshmallow
on a plate and told them that if
they didn't eat the marshmallow
for a certain length of time,
or something like five or 10
minutes, that they could get
two marshmallows instead.
And what happened was
that some of the children
ate the marshmallow
immediately, couldn't resist,
and some children did
not eat the marshmallow
and were able to wait.
And the children who didn't
eat the marshmallow often
had some sort of strategy.
Some of them closed their eyes.
Some of them sang songs.
Some of them did a little dance.
Some kids turned around.
You see them doing this-- really
using all sorts of strategies
that they can to not
eat the marshmallow.
But they had some way of
controlling their urge.
And what the study found
was that 10 years later,
the youngsters who showed
restraint as four-year-olds
were doing better in school,
had superior relationships
with their peers, and managed
stress much more successfully
than those who were unable
to exercise restraint.
And they have continued.
I think they're still following
these subjects, who are now
in their 50s, and
it has been shown
that the effects have
been long-lasting.
Even more recent research
shows that self-control
is more strongly associated
with success in school than IQ.
And other studies show that
self-control not only produces
better behaved, better adjusted,
and morally-oriented kids,
but it also produces people
who are just happier overall.
So that part of the brain
that I was talking about,
the prefrontal cortex,
which is a work in progress,
is not develop really
fully until the 20s.
So we might be inclined
to think there's not
much we can do about it.
But really, you set the
stage for that self-control
and learning those skills
when they're young.
And there's a real
opportunity when
they're young to have
influence over that.
So where does self-control
show up in our behavior?
It shows up in the way we
control our words-- not
always saying
what's on our mind.
It shows up in controlling
physical actions.
It shows up in showing patience,
appreciation for what one has,
eating properly,
being able to cope
with not getting
everything one wants.
This is a big one for
kids-- learning that.
Conserving resources, being
able to resist temptations,
making the best of what
one has and not whining.
I'm sure no one has kids
who whine here, right?
Taking turns,
appreciating what one has.
And here's something
really important.
When your kids become tweens and
teens, having some self-control
and some strategies
for inhibiting urges
really helps them
in not succumbing
to the bad influences of others.
So here are five
things you can do
to help your child
develop self-control.
First and foremost--
and this is really
the most important-- is
to model it yourself.
And that goes with almost
all behaviors, is modeling.
Keeping an appropriate volume,
choosing your words carefully,
showing patience,
conserving materials,
and a really important
one is showing
how you deal with
stress and frustration.
So you're about to leave
the house in the morning.
I know what it's like.
It's chaotic in the morning.
And you're trying to leave.
You can't find your keys
and you start to get tense.
Your voice starts to rise.
And what you can do is to
model for your children--
Mommy's really upset right now.
I'm going to take a deep breath,
and I'm going to count to 10.
Let's count together.
And when I feel more
relaxed, then we'll
be able to look for my
keys together and solve
this problem.
And when you model that
kind of self-control,
your kids really pick up on it.
Secondly, you can create
real scenarios for your kids
to start to exercise a
little bit of self-control,
and that's waiting, sharing,
cooperating, giving feedback
to each other.
One of the examples
that I love to use
and I used a lot
with my children
was I used to cook
with my children a lot,
bake with them a lot,
when they were a little.
And there's so
many opportunities
for having to wait or
measure something or take
turns with another child.
So let's say you
have two children
and they're at the
table, and they both
want to do the mixing.
But there's only one
spoon to mix with.
So one child is mixing.
And you give the other child
the strategy of waiting.
Maybe you sing a verse of "Old
McDonald" while you're waiting,
or maybe you count if the
child's learning how to count.
But you give them a
strategy for waiting
for that limited amount
of time, and then
they see that it's their
turn, and then you reverse it
and the other child
gets a chance.
It's a perfect opportunity to
teach self-control and sharing,
and you can use that
kind of strategy.
The caveat for that about
teaching self-control-- and I
want to be really
clear about this.
It's very important
that these strategies
be used in an
age-appropriate manner.
So parents tend to overestimate
their children's ability
to wait and do nothing
for long periods of time.
And actually, a lot of
children's misbehavior
is just out of boredom.
So you want to
make sure that you
don't have a two-year-old
sit there and be expected
to wait quietly and do
nothing for 15 minutes.
It's just not going to happen.
But you can give them
strategies for waiting
for short periods of time
or not interrupting you
immediately-- that
kind of thing.
Also, I'm not
talking about babies.
I'm not talking
about newborns here.
Newborns need to have their
needs met immediately in order
to feel secure and to
develop that secure bond
with their parent.
So breastfeeding on demand and
holding and cuddling your child
and responding to
them immediately
is really important.
And so I'm not talking about
keeping a newborn waiting.
A third way we teach our
children self-control
is to find examples in real life
of people exhibiting control--
reading books
about self-control,
like "Lilly's Plastic Purse."
Dr. Seuss has lots of
great books about it.
A fourth way is to do community
service with your children.
It really helps them to
appreciate what they have.
And there are lots of great
community service projects
you can do with young children.
You can have them make
cards for elderly people.
You can work to help
clean up a playground.
And you can change those kind
of community service projects
as they get older to be
more appropriate for the age
that they're at, but
showing your children
what it's like to
do for someone else
or someone who doesn't have
as much as they have or needs
something gives them a greater
feeling of appreciation
for what they have.
And finally, I really think it's
important to teach your child
the difference between
needing and wanting.
So you hear your child "I
need this." "I need this."
It's really important to
clarify to them the difference
between things that they need
and things that they want,
and not that things that they
want are invalid to want,
but that they understand
the difference.
So I'm going to read
a little something
that my daughter wrote.
My daughter is my
third child, and this
is something she wrote I
think when she was maybe
in sixth grade or something.
This is from Shoshanna.
"There was an American
Girl doll named Josephina."
Everybody here knows
about American Girl dolls?
If you have a child that's old
enough, or if you have a girl.
They're really
expensive and you get
into a whole thing with American
Girl dolls if you buy one.
"But there was an American
Girl doll named Josephina
that I really wanted
for Hanukkah the year
that I was about to turn seven.
It wasn't just one of the
interests that come and go.
I was really in
love with this doll.
I kept telling Mom I needed
her-- I needed Josephina.
And this is always
launch Mom or Dad
into a speech about
what needing really was.
But I kept insisting
that I needed her,
and because I couldn't learn
to say that I wanted her,
I didn't get her for
Hanukkah that year.
I was horrified.
I tried to show appreciation
for the gifts that I got anyway,
and life went on.
And then once I realized that
life went on, I told my mom.
I said, you know what?
Life went on.
I didn't get Josephina.
I guess I didn't need her.
And Josephina was my
seventh birthday present."
So you can see that there's
opportunities to teach children
the difference, and that it
will make an impact on them.
And I think it's one
of the greatest gifts
that we can give
to our children.
So before I get
to questions, I'll
tell one more stories
about self-control,
and then I'll finish up here.
This was with my
youngest son, Lev.
And he was in
preschool at the time.
And he was very
mathematically-oriented,
and he knew how to
count pretty early on.
And we used to play this game.
It was a Thomas the
Tank Engine game,
and it had different
sized puzzle pieces
with different numbers on them,
and the bigger the number,
the bigger the piece.
And you were trying to put the
sized pieces in the right place
in your puzzle and
finish your train.
If you finished your train
and completed your train first
you won the game.
So there was one piece that was
the number five, the largest
number, and that was
the biggest piece.
And if you got the
number five, you
were probably going
to win the game.
So he had his friend Rachel
over for a play date,
and they were playing this game.
And right off the bat,
she spins number five.
And Lev looks up at me
with this look of horror.
He knows this is not good.
And I just sort of
smiled at him and sort of
nodded, because we had
talked about this-- that when
he played games
with other children
that you need to
play by the rules.
And he knew.
And tears are starting
to well up in his eyes.
He's about to be
overcome by the fact
that he's not going to
get the number five.
And I see him sort of
take a deep breath.
And he took the number five
and he handed it to Rachel,
and then he took his turn.
And then he looked up at me and
he said, I got myself together.
So it is something that you can
teach in age-appropriate ways.
So just to conclude, I've talked
about three of the chapters
in the book.
There are many,
many other topics.
In fact, there are 52.
They deal with picky
eating, sleep, separation,
extracurricular activities,
sibling relationships,
which is a really big topic.
And each chapter covers just
one topic to think about.
And I encourage
parents to really
self-reflect with some questions
at the end of the chapter
and then to look at
that checklist of things
at the very end of chapter
that will give them
things to think about
throughout the week,
or however long it
takes for that strategy
to become a habit.
I'd like to summarize
by saying that parenting
is one of the most
challenging and important jobs
that we have.
We're taught how to write.
We're taught how to read.
But most people aren't
taught how to parent,
and we're expected
to know how to do it.
But good parenting
isn't all instinct.
Some of it's instinct,
yes, but not all of it.
And part of being a good parent
is learning about parenting
and working at it.
It is possible to raise kids
who are respectful and kind
and engaged members
of the community.
I've done it.
In fact, I think my kids
are my best advertisement.
And I want to leave
with those two ideas
that I said originally,
which are running
throughout the book, and that
is that how you parent really
does matter.
And see yourself on a
journey, a parenting journey.
It's a journey of hard work,
but it's also a journey of joy
as you see the results.
And secondly, this idea of
parenting with intention.
I encourage you to think
about what kind of person
you want your child to be, and
then to parents accordingly
and make decisions
based on that.
Trust me, the hard work
that you put in now
will pay off in the end, and
it will pay off big time.
Thank you so much.
I'm happy to take questions.
AUDIENCE: I have
two-and-a-half-year-old twins,
one of whom has much better
language skills than the other.
And I'm curious
if you could talk
a little bit about
the transition
from teaching lessons
through showing,
or just modeling behavior, to
having the advantage of being
able to tell and explain.
So just to talk a little bit
about age-appropriate teaching,
particularly, selfishly,
for me at the--
MEG AKABAS: How
old are they again?
AUDIENCE: Two and a half.
MEG AKABAS: Two and a half.
Right.
So, yeah.
A lot of it is modeling
at the beginning,
but also you can
start with stories.
That's the best place to
start, really, with young kids.
So start to tell stories
with the dolls or the animals
or whatever, your characters,
or even just vocal
stories about situations
that sort of impart
the lessons that
you want to teach.
Because lecturing and explaining
the big moral of consequences
of things isn't going
to really go with
a two-and-a-half-year-old.
But there are a lot
of opportunities
to work into stories and
books that you choose,
finding things that teach those
lessons you want to learn.
So I would really
encourage being
creative with storytelling.
It's the perfect way
to teach lessons.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I have two
girls, eight and 11.
And my challenge with
my older daughter
is starting-- I think she's
in those preteen years
where she's started
to push boundaries.
And I can be the best and the
worst mother in the same day.
And, of course, there are
other people's parents
who let them do things.
And we try our best to say
that we are responsible for you
as parents, and not them.
And they will do what's
best with their kids.
But that doesn't always kind of
seem to strike the right chord.
Are there any ways
that I can kind of
help her realize that the
decisions we take that
may not seem like the most
probably popular decisions,
but they're kind of good
for her in the long term?
MEG AKABAS: And do you
explain the reasons
behind it, what values
you're trying to impart?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
For the simple reason--
let me give an example.
Both my kids are in the
habit of saying when they're
hungry that "I'm
starving." and some of it
really is to upset
me, because I don't
think they know
what starving is.
So I kind of vent.
I was really upset,
and I actually
showed them YouTube videos
of what starving means
and how kids do starve
and what it actually is.
And of course the result was
that they started crying,
and they told me that,
why would I show them
such horrible things
and it was so mean.
But I wanted them to understand
that they could tell me
that, Mom, I'm hungry.
But don't use the term
starving because it's actually
a problem [INAUDIBLE].
And I think they understood
it for all of one week,
and then it was kind of
back to the same old,
you know, I'm really starving.
Can you give me
something to eat?
I can't wait.
And just kind of, you
know-- the sustenance
doesn't seem to be there.
MEG AKABAS: So part of some
of the strategies that run
in the book are about
belief follows behavior.
And some of it is
just about doing.
Like, they may not
understand it now,
or they may have understood
it briefly but they forget it.
But if you do something enough,
you begin to believe it.
So if you require your
children to say to you,
"I'm hungry right now; I
want something to eat,"
instead of "I'm starving" before
you give them something to eat,
they will start to learn
that they need to just say
I'm hungry or I'd really
like something to eat.
So they'll start to
have that behavior.
And when you have a
behavior over time,
you start to believe it.
And then maybe
eventually they'll
start to really
understand deeply,
or you'll come across people
who really are starving again.
But part of it is just
having them do it.
So you want to
have consequences.
I mean, they're teenagers,
and the consequence
for them coming in and saying
"I'm starving" is you say,
I don't respond to that.
Is there something that
you wanted to ask me?
Is there something that's
real that you want to tell me?
And they'll say, you know, I'd
really like something to eat.
Oh.
You want something to eat.
Sure.
I'm happy to get you
something to eat.
And that works with
whining, by the way-- when
children whine and they
come to you, "I'm hungry."
Well, when you respond
to that with, sure,
what do you want to eat?
What are you teaching them?
You're teaching them to whine.
And if you say to them,
I didn't hear a question.
Is there a question
you wanted to ask me?
I'm hungry.
That doesn't sound
like a question.
If there's something
you want from me,
I'm here when you want it.
I'd like something to eat.
Oh, you want something to eat.
We have plenty to eat.
What would you like?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
I have two boys and two girls.
And what I'm finding
is, the boys,
they get along pretty well with
each other, and girls also.
But they fight like crazy,
the boys between the girls.
MEG AKABAS: You mean the boys
and the girls fight each other.
AUDIENCE: And so
I'm wondering if you
could talk about some
strategies for that.
MEG AKABAS: That's a
really good question.
Sibling relationship is
one of my favorite topics.
I happen to have four
children who adore each other
and treat each other with
such respect and kindness.
It is the great joy of my life.
So I have three boys and a girl.
And I have a couple
of strategies.
The main one I
would say for you--
which has to do with you
saying that they get along
with each other in pairs,
but not with each other--
is to find some things that they
can cooperate on all together,
something positive that
they can all do together.
And that could be a
production of a-- I
don't know how old they are.
But it could be
getting a show together
to present when they
go to Grandma's house.
Or it could be a
community service project
that they're doing together.
Get them to cooperate
positively on something
that they enjoy doing or
that they can enjoy doing,
and that will get them
working in tandem.
They'll get to see that they
enjoy each other's company.
The other thing-- and
I give some strategies
about that in the book.
Because it has something to
do with ages, and sometimes
it's one child teaching
a child another thing
or having a hobby
that they do together.
But try to pair them up in
ways where they're not always
paired up the two
girls and the two boys.
So one of the
girls, you might be
able to find an interests that
they have with one of the boys
that they could do together.
Tal did scuba diving
training with my daughter,
and that was something
that they learned
how to do together that
they still do together.
So trying to find something
that they can cooperate on
across the sexes
there, I would say.
For parents who have
children who just say,
you know, my kids are
really competitive
and have trouble getting along.
One of the best anecdotes
for sibling rivalry
is individual attention.
But that's not to
solve your problem
in terms of children getting
along with each other
that you want them to do.
But in terms of
competition, that's
a big strategy-- is
to make sure you're
carving out individual time
with each parent for each child,
either on a daily basis, small,
or on a weekly basis, a little
larger, or on a monthly
basis, a full day
alone with that parent.
Individual attention is key
to help sibling rivalry.
That was a really good question.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a 20-month-old.
And actually just this weekend,
we took her to-- well, it
as Mother's Day
weekend, so we went
to a pretty nice restaurant.
And I had a little
debate with my husband.
I thought it was OK
for her to walk around
in an area that's kind of quiet
in the restaurant, like closer
to the bathroom area.
Because she's one
and a half, and she
had to sit there for like,
two, close to three hours.
And that's really tough.
But then my husband did not my
baby to walk around by herself.
Like, he wanted to hold
her hands at all time
while he was walking.
But then I felt like
that's too much constraint
on a one-and-a-half-year-old,
essentially.
I'm wondering what
are your thoughts?
But then his idea
was it's not safe
for her to walk in a restaurant.
And she doesn't know
that this area's safe
versus a normal
crowded restaurant.
So he wanted to have an
idea that if it's indoor,
you hold hands with us.
If it's outdoor, then it's
OK to walk by yourself.
I'm just curious what
are your thoughts?
MEG AKABAS: Right,
and then sometimes
outdoor is not OK to be
walking without hands.
It depends on the situation.
It's hard for me to say in
that particular situation.
I don't know how the
restaurant was situated,
where the kitchen was, were
there dangerous things,
were there other people.
So I'm going to speak
in general about when
you have a disagreement
with your spouse,
because this is
a big topic also.
I see some people smiling.
The first thing is--
and I don't know
how relevant this was in
this particular situation--
is to try not to undermine
each other, to try not to have
that disagreement in
front of your child.
So go with one parent
and stick with it,
and then you can
talk about it later
and try to figure
out what you're
going to do in future situations
when something like this
comes up.
So now you have this
opportunity to talk about it.
And, in general,
what I say if there's
a real conflict between
doing one thing or the other,
to choose the one that has
the least danger of going bad,
of being detrimental to
the child or the child's
development.
So in this case, he's
worried about safety.
I don't know how
unsafe that was.
But that's probably
a valid concern.
And it seems like that
would be the choice
to go with, because
it's the least
risk of doing something wrong.
Like being over-safe,
not so bad.
Being unsafe, bad.
So you could decide
ahead of time
that when you're in
situations where you're
undecided about whether she
needs to be holding someone's
hand or not, that you're going
to err on the side of safety.
And that would be something you
would have to compromise on.
And maybe you'll be
able to work over
time discussing with him
outside of the earshot of her
whether she's able to develop
a little more independence
in situations like that.
The other thing I would say
is if you're in restaurants,
it's really important to
bring activities for the kids
to do at the table.
And I know that's hard
with a baby or a toddler.
They want to move around.
But bringing lots
of books, bringing
lots of just something--
little toys to play with,
characters you can tell stories.
So many parents
complain about kids
misbehaving in restaurants.
It's really hard for a kid
to sit with nothing to do.
Kids just don't sit and talk.
That's just not
something they do,
even if they are
at the age to talk.
It's not an activity for them.
So bring things for them
to keep them occupied,
either with each
other or by themselves
or one parent reads while
the other parent talks
to the other person
that you're with so
that you don't really have an
issue with a child misbehaving.
But if you want to
let her roam around
and you feel like you're
in disagreement about how
much control to
have over that, I
would always err on
the side of the parent
with the least detrimental
effect of going wrong.
I'll give you an
example of this.
My husband and I
had a disagreement
about whether-- we have
a rule in our family--
no physical force.
The only sort of physical
touching that goes on
is affectionate touching.
That includes elbowing,
tickling, nudging, nothing.
There's only kind touching in
our house, affection, hugs.
My husband wanted to play
sword fights with the kids
when they were young,
because that's what he did.
And we don't have any
weapons in our house, either.
And so he wanted to do
the rolled up swords.
And so we had a thing
about whether or not
sword fights were OK.
And we just couldn't
agree on it.
My husband's a pretty
nonviolent person,
but he really thought
this was a great idea.
And I just thought
it was always going
to lead to someone
being unhappy.
So we had a big talk
about it, and we
decided that the decision
that would have the least
risk of having a
detrimental effect
was not having sword fights.
Like, that's OK-- kids
don't have sword fights.
And we invented some
other game with nets
and stuffed animals that was
really fun that the kids liked.
And that was how we
resolved that issue.
AUDIENCE: What are your
thoughts on screen time?
Google has YouTube,
which is quite popular.
So we have a 19-month-old.
So we really don't put
him in front of television
that much-- sometimes
on and off on YouTube.
But generally, it's an
ongoing trend, right?
You see it a lot more.
MEG AKABAS: Yeah.
It's a really big problem.
And, believe me, I'm not
anti-technology or screen time
for kids at all, but
under the age of two,
it's been shown to really
not be a good thing.
Kids really only learn
and need to learn
about the world around them
and to develop emotionally well
by interacting with
a real, live person.
And the more time they spend in
front of the screen, the less
time they're doing that.
So the Pediatric Association
advises no screen time
under the age of two, and
then in small increments.
You could have a half an hour
a day of watching Sesame Street
or using some educational video.
And just be really careful
to keep your guidelines.
Make a decision about them.
Say, OK.
I think an hour
feels about right.
They're at this age.
It feels about right.
And then stick to it.
And then also to be very
good about interacting
with them sometimes
during that time.
Sometimes it's a good activity
to have them do something
alone, but it's
also an opportunity
to do something with them--
so watching something
together or playing a
video game together.
Make it part of the
interaction as they get older
so that it's not
they're isolated
with a screen with no
interaction in the family.
AUDIENCE: What if it's
puzzles on the tablet?
MEG AKABAS: Yeah.
I mean, that's great.
And my kids played a lot
of educational-- back
in the day it was
just computer games.
That's all we had.
We didn't have video games.
But computer games,
educational puzzles
that they do
individually-- it's great.
But just have it be a
certain amount of time.
And you could have the rule
that it's only on weekends,
or on school days, it's only a
half an hour as they get older.
And constantly be developing
that depending on their age,
and then just be very
consistent with it.
But under the age of two,
it's really not recommended.
There's certain
very limited amounts
of times where it's helpful
to have a child be engaged
with something else
for a moment while you
do something important
that's short.
That's OK.
But otherwise, making it a
habit and part of their daily
activities, not so good.
AUDIENCE: On an earlier
one of your responses
related to kids whining--
MEG AKABAS: Kids whining.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think for an older
kid, like seven, 10-year-old,
it's a little easier
to communicate.
At least they understand
what you're saying.
My daughter's about two
and a half right now.
How do you deal with
kids [INAUDIBLE]
at that age, their whining?
When they want something,
instead of-- they
just whine about it.
How do you actually deal
with it so that they actually
are properly communicating
what they are looking for?
MEG AKABAS: So, it's
really the same strategy.
I know this may
seem like, harsh.
But actually, if you
don't give in to whining,
they won't do it anymore.
And that goes at age seven and
it goes at age two and a half.
So my kids stopped
whining very early on.
And people would say,
your kids never whine.
Your four-year-old,
five-year-old, they
don't whine.
They ask for things
when they want it.
And it's because I
never responded to it.
And when I say
never responded, it
doesn't mean I
just, blank stare.
They didn't get
what they wanted.
And a two-and-a-half-year-old
is able to say,
please may I have some water?
Or please can I have a snack?
That's not an
unrealistic expectation
for a two-and-a-half-year-old.
Happier They just
may have gotten
in the habit of
whining and knowing
that they get what they
want when they whine.
So being consistent whenever
you hear that tone of voice.
And even if they ask, "I
want a glass of water."
You say, if you want
a glass of water,
I need you to stay it in
a voice that's respectful
and ask in a nice way.
That's a whiny voice.
And you can model it for them.
Please say, can I
have a glass of water?
And they'll say, no, I can't.
I'm too tired.
[WHINING]
It's like, well,
when you're ready,
I'm ready to give you a glass
of water when you ask nicely.
And if they really
want it, they'll do it.
And it doesn't take
that many times
when they'll realize that
that whining has no effect.
But you have to be consistent.
But two and a half is
not too early to start.
And you'll be so happy
you did, because then you
don't have whiners.
It's really nice.
AUDIENCE: Earlier you
talked about teaching kids
to wait and have self-control.
My son is 14 months.
And you say and we understand
at early ages, it's not--
MEG AKABAS: Age-appropriate
to wait a long tong.
AUDIENCE: And they need
immediate help for their needs.
So what's the appropriate
timeline for little kids
to start being taught this?
MEG AKABAS: So it depends on
what you're asking them to do.
I mean, a 14-month-old can
have some self-soothing skills.
They can learn how to
entertain themselves
for short periods of time.
And when they start
to speak, kids
can learn to ask for things
with please and thank you.
I mean, that's not unrealistic.
So it depends on
exactly what you're
talking about in terms
of having self-control.
But they can have some
self-control-- learning,
for example, not to throw
their cup on the floor
when they're done with it.
You know how toddlers will do
that off of the high chair.
Thank you.
I haven't used a high chair
in so long I don't even
remember the name of it.
So, for example, a child
who, you give them food
and they start playing with
it and they're throwing it.
And you keep telling them
to stop and they don't.
They can learn not to do that
anymore, because you say,
you know what?
You throw that off
again, and I'm not
going to give you any more.
And then you stick with that.
They'll learn to
control that urge
to throw the food off the table.
So it depends on what it is
that you're talking about.
So I can't give you
a particular age,
but you can start,
certainly, at 14 months,
with certain very
small-- you know,
I'm going to give you the toy.
You give it back to me.
We're not going to throw things.
So, for example, a child who
throws blocks at 14 months.
And maybe they're
hurting someone else
by throwing the blocks.
And you tell them not to
throw it and they do it again,
then the consequences--
the block gets take away.
That is a child learning
self-control at that age,
that there is a
consequence for something
and that they can't just throw
anything they want to throw.
So you can be teaching
lessons of self-control,
but you have to
try to understand--
and maybe that's through
reading, and depending
on what the skill is
that you're trying
to teach-- about when
it is age-appropriate.
But I can't say
there's one age where
you start teaching
self-control, because it's
sort of a progressive
thing that goes on.
And you have to have some
idea of what's realistic.
And I think you can have
some sense of that--
whether it's something that's
realistic for your child to do
or not, and then
you make a decision
and then you
implement the strategy
and do it consistently.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you--
this is with regard to what you
were saying about transferring
authority and not letting--
MEG AKABAS: About not what?
AUDIENCE: Not letting
your child be in charge.
MEG AKABAS: Not letting your
child be in charge-- right.
Who's in charge?
AUDIENCE: Telling the child
rather than asking questions.
So I was wondering
if you find this
useful in terms of a certain
age-0- let's say below puberty.
And I'm asking this
question because there
was another presentation here by
psychologist Daniel Siegel, who
was talking--
MEG AKABAS: Daniel Siegel
is one of my mentors.
I love him.
AUDIENCE: So he was talking
about puberty and adolescence
in particular, like being
a very important period
in the formation
of a child's brain.
And that this is the time
when actually children
are most creative.
So a useful strategy is actually
to step back a little bit
and give them some
room to be [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MEG AKABAS: Yes.
What he's asking is,
when I said about who's
in charge-- and this
author Daniel Siegel, who's
a very well-noted
child psychologist,
talks about letting
your child have some
say and to develop
their creativity
and have some independence.
Yes.
Absolutely.
And, in fact, I have
a chapter in the book
called "Choices, Choices."
It's just as important to give
your child choices about things
and to give them lots
of room for creativity
and to make decisions.
The important
thing is to be very
clear in your mind
about what things
they should have choices about.
And the choices
about things that
cross the line against
your better judgment
or against your family
values are not things
that they should have choices
about, or behaviors, whenever
you want to instill in them--
you need to make those choices.
And there are lots of things you
can give your children choices
about.
And as they get older, you can
talk to them about it and say,
you know, I want to find a way
for you to be able to do this,
but we have these rules.
Let's talk about what might
be an appropriate boundary,
or what might be an appropriate
solution to this problem.
So I totally agree
with him that children
should have a lot of
say in many things,
and it's a bad thing
to stifle that.
But you have to be clear about
which things are the things
that they should-- so
if your child wants
to stay out until 1 o'clock in
an unsafe area or go to a party
where it's unsupervised
or something
and that's against your
better judgment, that's not
an instance where
it's good for a child
to kind of figure
out things themselves
and for you to step back.
If you really feel that's
against your better judgment,
then it's important to stick.
And it's not good for the
child to be in charge, still.
TAL AKABAS: But
what do you think
about changing the parenting
style from authoritative, what
you were saying, to permissive,
let's say, after age 12 or 14,
when they get into adolescence?
MEG AKABAS: Yeah.
I think that when you're
talking about permissive,
you're talking about
having some rules
and not really keeping them.
And so that's not really
what he's talking about.
I don't think he's talking
about being permissive.
I think he's talking
about having fewer things
that you have guidelines about,
fewer rules, because it's not
as necessary, but that
you keep the boundaries
with those rules.
So that's what I would say to
that-- that it's not really
a change in
parenting style, it's
a change in how you implement
the authoritative style,
that you're going to
be less restrictive.
There are certain things
that you're just not going
to have rules about
because you trust
your child's judgment
at that point.
And you find that
if you're pretty
consistent in the younger
years that your child will
get to know.
They will start to
have good judgment.
I had very few rules with
my kids as teenagers.
They didn't have a curfew.
There were very few
rules. [INAUDIBLE]
because they were
self-regulating.
They, by then, knew how
to make good choices.
So I don't believe that you have
to have rules, rules, rules,
rules all the time.
And if your kids
have really learned
how to take in a
lot of what you've
been trying to teach them, you
won't need that many rules,
actually.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
MEG AKABAS: You're welcome.
Thank you so much for coming.
I'm going to show you-- so my
book, "52 Weeks of Parenting
Wisdom.
I'll show you what
it looks like.
It's available on Amazon.
I'm also on Facebook,
if you'd like
to follow me to
get some parenting
tips and some
research that I post.
And I answer
questions online, too.
I'm under parenting-solutions,
parenting solutions.
And if you have any
questions afterward
and want to come talk to me up
here, I'm happy to talk to you.
Thank you so much for
coming, and have a good day.